en octobre la racine fête ses deux ans
d'existence l'association compte près de
500 adhérents
pour ce faire ils payent 8 euros par an
de cotisation pour rappel un euro est
égale à une racine et la monnaie permet
de favoriser une économie circulaire et
locales le bilan reste mitigé
on rencontre deux obstacles le premier
finalement c'est que les particuliers
sont très peu nombreux à rentrer dans le
jeu du coup on a les professionnels qui
dit oui moi personne demande d'utiliser
la monnaie locale je vois pas pourquoi
je la prendrai le deuxième point c'est
finalement les pouvoirs publics
je pense par exemple aux communes
collectivités territoriales qui devrait
pouvoir adhérer aux monnaies locales
cela n'a pas découragé sylvie boes
d'adhérer fidèle à l'association dès sa
création elle cotise à hauteur de 45
euros par an et cinq de ses clients
règlent enracine chaque mois la gérante
voit toujours l'intérêt d'utiliser la
monnaie notamment pour payer ses
fournisseurs
le fait de payer en euros en fin de
compte après cet argent va aller à la
banque va être utilisé dix ans et après
donc cet argent à la banque on ne sait
pas où elle va à qui elle va servir à
peut-être à l'international mondialement
et c'est non on ne sait pas à quelle fin
alors que là si je le paye enracine
obligatoirement je sais qu'il va les
utiliser obligatoirement en local et que
ça va la faire et vga une dynamique pour
l'avenir elles restent intéressés par
l'utilisation de cette monnaie tant que
la racine existera